[Musica]
come specie umana siamo nati esploratori
e siamo ancora esploratori
queste sono le parole di karl saganne
uno dei più importanti divulgatori
scientifici del secolo scorso
secondo cui il viaggio è insito nel
nostro dna e un istinto che abbiamo è
voluto per sopravvivere in una realtà
che non smette mai di cambiare viaggiare
e l'esperienza definitiva capace di
portarci lontano della nostra comfort
zone per riportare indietro qualcosa di
nuovo per noi e per gli altri
e l'apoteosi del cambiamento e questa
continua ricerca di stimoli nuovi
nasconde un aspetto molto importante
sulla nostra natura fondamentalmente
cambiare non è qualcosa che ci accade a
cambiare è un elemento essenziale della
vita biologica come la conosciamo i
continui stimoli nuovi che provengono
dall'esterno sono quelli che spingono le
cellule a cambiare a evolversi spingono
le nostre ossa rinforzarsi il corpo a
crescere aumentare o ridurre massa
muscolare
il corpo si ciba di stimoli esterni per
affermare se stesso nel mondo
circostante e l'alternativa al
cambiamento e l'atrofia e la
degenerazione e la morte
infine ecco è questo è particolarmente
importante per l'organo che ci rende più
di tutti umani che ci permette di
esprimere emozioni intelletto relazione
il cervello e se lo stimolo vitalizzante
nel caso del muscolo e la forza
meccanica nel caso del cervello è
l'insieme di esperienze che viviamo ora
per il cervello non esiste cosa più
importante che causi atrofia del vivere
sempre nelle stesse condizioni nello
stesso ambiente nello stesso posto
e questa monotonia non è solamente uno
stato mentale è qualcosa che
letteralmente uccide il cervello la
monotonia porta alla degenerazione di
aree cerebrali come l'ippocampo
compromettendo la memoria riduce la
liberazione di serotonina porta ad
anomalie comportamentali come ansia e
depressione
la monotonia ora il cervello allo stesso
tempo
l'organo che più di tutti si adatta nel
più flessibile e formato da circa 100
miliardi di cellule che sono collegate
tra di loro da sinapsi come fossero
circuiti elettrici e il bello è che
tutti gli stimoli provenienti
dall'esterno hanno un impatto
sull'anatomia del cervello rimodellando
e plasmando continuamente le sue
connessioni
la morale è che il cervello cambia
letteralmente e lo fa in base alle
esperienze che viviamo ora se questi
stimoli esterni hanno un impatto così
importante sul nostro cervello se solo
avessimo uno strumento per fornire al
cervello gli stimoli che vogliamo gli
scenari che desideriamo potremmo guidare
questo processo di rimodellamento verso
degli obiettivi che ad esempio
potrebbero essere terapeutici e oggi
questo strumento per quanto perfettibile
ma in rapida evoluzione c'è e digitale e
si chiama realtà virtuale che è semplice
e complesso allo stesso tempo in cui due
semplici lenti è uno schermo davanti ci
danno la possibilità di illudere il
cervello di trovarsi in un altro posto
realistico interattivo ma completamente
digitale quando parliamo di salute il
ruolo della mente del cervello non sono
meno importanti del ruolo del corpo
la motivazione l'immaginazione
supportano il processo di guarigione e
l'emozione e la memoria consolidano
questo processo ci sono però dei momenti
in cui nella terapia nella malattia
le condizioni sono così estreme da
abbattere
la mente ed impedirle di svolgere la sua
funzione nel bel mezzo della malattia ci
viene impossibile immaginare
un'alternativa oltre quelle mura che ci
sono stati imposte da una condizione
indesiderata che quella di essere
paziente allora proprio in questo caso
la realtà virtuale può aiutare la mente
ad andare oltre questi limiti aiutandola
lì dove comincia a zoppicare a causa
dell'estrema difficoltà diventando una
sorta di protesi cognitiva proprio
perché la salute non è limitata solo
dalla condizione del corpo ma anche dal
benessere mentale poco più di due anni
fa abbiamo fondato io ei miei colleghi
una società di start up una società di
salute digitale che abbiamo chiamato
soft air studios e da qui mission è
fondamentalmente quella di portare le
potenzialità e le applicazioni della
realtà virtuale
dovunque la mente diventi un limite al
processo di guarigione aiutando i
pazienti migliorando la qualità della
loro vita supportandoli durante il
percorso terapeutico cercando di ridurre
anche la somministrazione di farmaci e
rendendo il paziente anche una parte
attiva del percorso terapeutico perché
terapia non è un processo passivo ma
significa anche rendere il paziente
reattivo e recettivo della guarigione
allo stesso tempo ci siamo resi conto
che il benessere mentale non può essere
standardizzato non è uguale per tutti
allora è fondamentale come molte altre
applicazioni di salute digitale
raccogliere dati oggettivi su quello che
l'impatto della realtà virtuale sul
benessere mentale dei pazienti
dati che noi stiamo raccogliendo è che
puntiamo a rendere sempre più complesso
come processo per monitorare come cambia
il benessere dei pazienti nel tempo ma
anche per adattare quelli che sono gli
scenari virtuali alle necessità di ogni
singolo paziente
questo perché a parte i dati la
personalizzazione è il secondo elemento
più importante
della salute digitale e qui arriviamo al
progetto di cui parlava marco prima noi
abbiamo sviluppato un primo progetto
dedicato a quella che la fascia più
debole di pazienti i bambini questo
progetto e tommy un progetto in realtà
virtuale che viene fornito in forma di
gioco ma che coinvolge non solo i
bambini ma anche i loro genitori che non
sono meno pazienti dei bimbi e che noi
oltre a quattro ospedali in italia è un
ospedale all'estero a huston abbiamo
introdotto proprio qui a taranto al
santissima annunziata
grazie al coraggioso supporto di due
associazioni locali che sono delle vb
project è arciragazzi taranto ora
applicare la realtà virtuale al
benessere mentale come strumento per
supportare benessere mentale dei
pazienti apre delle porte sul nuovo
ambito che viene chiamato embodied
medici o medicina incorporata in cui è
possibile grazie alla realtà virtuale
portare la mente delle persone
all'interno di nuovi corpi digitali o
avatar ed esporla a belle esperienze e
stimoli che possono essere utili a
guidarla verso stati positivi e verso
condizioni a sfondo terapeutico quali
sono queste applicazioni ce ne sono
tantissime ne citerò giusto alcune una
di queste la più antica e un certo senso
già iniziata negli anni 90 è quella
della gestione del dolore quando due
pionieri kaufman e patterson utilizzare
una realtà virtuale per ridurre la
percezione del dolore in pazienti
ustionati verso cui nemmeno gli oppioidi
facevano qualcosa
quello che scoprirono era che non solo
la realtà virtuale capace di ridurre la
percezione di dolore ma dopo aver
testato con risonanza magnetica
scoprirono che fondamentalmente la
realtà virtuale spegne letteralmente i
centri del dolore all'interno del
cervello molto più di una semplice
distrazione
lo stesso fan continuo successivamente
nell'ambito delle fobie
digitalizzando tutta una serie di
protocolli di terapia d'esposizione
classici attraverso cui normalmente i
pazienti vengono esposti gradualmente
progressivamente agli stimoli di cui
hanno paura per esempio iran
come potete vedere in questa slide è
quello che scoprì e che i cambiamenti
indotti la realtà virtuale nel nostro
cervello per duravano anche dopo aver
rimosso il visore dà morale in questo
caso è che superare una paura in realtà
virtuale e un successo reale altre
applicazioni ancora dalle fobie allo
stress post traumatico migliaia di
militari di ritorno dalla guerra
soffrono di stress postraumatico dopo i
traumi appunto vissuti durante la guerra
beh da tantissimi anni la realtà
virtuale viene utilizzata per far loro
rivivere in maniera estremamente
controllata quei traumi che nel loro
cervello hanno creato un loop
irrisolvibile e in molti casi sono
guariti ultima applicazione che vorrei
citare è quello della riabilitazione
la riabilitazione un percorso lungo un
percorso demotivante noioso ripetitivo
la realtà virtuale
poi a un certo senso arricchire questa
esperienza può aggiungere motivazione
coinvolgimento ma come strumento
cognitivo opportunamente progettato può
essere utilizzato per consolidare la
memoria e il recupero delle facoltà
motorie
ora quello che abbiamo visto e che nei
tanti pazienti che possono essere
trattati con realtà virtuale sono tre
gli aspetti che li caratterizzano
ossia una volta diventati i pazienti la
routine della loro vita viene
completamente sconvolta non ci sono più
punti di riferimento il loro futuro
incerto e questo causa una condizione di
stress cronico che non finisce mai e
terzo si isolano l'isolamento che non è
solamente fisico ma anche emotivo
sociale psicologico ma questi tre
aspetti non sono caratteristici sono dei
pazienti qui sulla terra
perché se l'esplorazione spaziale il
nostro futuro
beh nel momento stesso in cui una
persona mette un piede fuori da questo
pianeta diventa automaticamente un
paziente perché il suo corpo e la sua
mente vengono sottoposti a delle
condizioni estreme completamente diverse
pazienti e astronauti di una condizione
estremamente similare di isolamento di
stress infinito lontani anni luce della
loro con forza allora ad esempio se
l'esplorazione spaziale quindi puntare
ad esempio la colonizzazione della luna
allo sbarco su marte è una realtà il
tempo di permanenza degli astronauti
sulla nello spazio aumenterà e
cominciare a pensare al benessere
mentale degli astronauti non è più un
lavoro di fantasia ma è una concreta
priorità e vi faccio tre esempi di
applicazione luca parmitano in questo
momento rappresenta tutti noi e tutta
l'italia
tra le stelle come comandante della
stazione spaziale internazionale nella
missione beyond ma in questa foto a
parte luca parmitano troviamo un altro
protagonista la complessità la vita
nello spazio è fatta di dettagli di
regole ma anche di errori che sono
imperdonabili
immaginate cosa significa vivere in
quelle condizioni in uno stress che non
finisce mai
la realtà virtuale può essere utilizzata
per abituare gli astronauti a gestire le
situazioni di rischio a limitare
instabilità emotive che potrebbero
minare non solo le relazioni inter
sociali all'interno della crew ma anche
il successo della missione
guardate invece questa foto metri di
metallo e pulsante dove gli astronauti
passano e passeranno sempre di più tempo
lontani dalla terra è un ambiente fatto
di monotonia e come abbiamo visto la
monotonia e capace letteralmente di
uccidere la realtà virtuale in quel caso
può diventare uno strumento con cui
aggiungere abbondanza sensoriale alla
vita degli astronauti in modo da
preservare non solo il corpo ma anche
tutte le loro
colta piccolo psicologiche motorie
cognitive ed emotive un terzo aspetto
poco percepito e quello del inquinamento
acustico
gli astronauti vivono mesi in mezzo al
rumore costante che sicuramente non è
salutare la realtà virtuale può essere
utilizzata come strumento non solo per
offrire sollievo visivo ma anche uditivo
quindi creare delle camere digitali per
permettere agli astronauti di distrarsi
e recuperare forze ed energie pur
rimanendo sulla stazione spaziale
ora oggi noi viviamo nell'era dello
human brain project
dopo aver sequenziato il genoma
decodificare le funzioni di mente
cervello consapevolezza sono la prossima
frontiera per capire che cosa ci rende
davvero umani ovunque andremo qualsiasi
cosa faremo saremo sempre delle menti
che esplorano questo mondo attraverso
questo corpo che si tratti di paziente
circondati da mura visibili quelle degli
ospedali o mura invisibili quelle della
malattia o che si tratti degli
astronauti lassù tra le stelle
circondati da mura di metallo in tutti
questi casi anche se non possiamo sempre
cambiare lo spazio che circonda la
persona possiamo cambiare grazie alla
realtà virtuale lo spazio che viene
percepito dalla persona aiutando la
mente ad andare oltre i limiti che le
sono stati imposti e che non le sono
propri perché la nostra natura è quella
di essere liberi esploratorio grazie